hi chris how are you how you doing good
thanks so first of all what was your
reaction to being renewed
congratulations are you down if there's
20 more seasons you know what i'm having
a blast doing it i was very excited
it's amazing that the fans continue to
turn out and cbs obviously recognizes
that and we hold our own and
we feel so privileged to get to make
this show and to work with such a great
cast and writers and
yeah i'm i'm not going anywhere
is there anything that still surprises
you about ll
all the time
i mean he's somewhat predictable i laugh
about it sometimes because it's in the
way i used to kid with my dad because i
could predict things he was going to do
yeah there's a lot of things predictable
about about todd but there's a lot of
stuff where he just constantly surprises
you and he's an amazing guy i mean he
has a drive
and an ambition that is relentless and
it's it's really impressive and it's
it's kind of it's nice to be around you
know what i mean he kind of i feel
energized when i'm around him because he
has such a drive in in life in general
yeah have you seen the new batman
i have not no i'm playing catch-up
i literally just saw batman begins
with christian bell which was
unbelievable oh my god you were in and
so now i'm i know and i'm just about to
do the watch the dark knight next so you
have a requirement i know i know i've
got something to catch some catching up
to do i was i was pretty stung there so
you know i had to i had to back off for
a few years
oh don't say that no you're kidding me
it's great i'm happy to be a part of the
the batman universe it's amazing well
you definitely are and you're always
going to get batman questions and it was
it was a pleasure talking to you
congratulations